je crois que pour construire une nation
la connaissance de son histoire est
fondamentale et cela c'est le rôle de
l'éducation
c'est dans l'éducation que l'on doit
construire la connaissance de l'histoire
et la mémoire
c'est un moment de l'histoire qui n'est
pas encore entré dans l'histoire mais
vous comprenez que si l'on n'apprend
plus l'histoire de son pays aux jeunes
si on leur apprend par morceau les
histoires du monde avec des morceaux qui
ne sont plus chronologiquement
compréhensible alors évidemment on perd
le sens des chaudières
il y avait quelque chose qui s'appelait
le 8 mai 1945
donc il est commémorée dans toute la
france c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
important
simplement il ya eu un problème un
problème c'est qu'il ya un oubli de
l'histoire il ya une page de l'histoire
qui n'est pas écrite page de l'histoire
de france de notre pays qui n'est pas
écrit de celui de sétif guelma et
kherrata où il ya eu plus de quarante
mille morts massacrés par les colons
l'armée française le jour même où on
avait la libération la victoire contre
le fascisme le nazisme la cette histoire
là on la raconte nulle part ni dans les
manuels scolaires ni quelques rares
historiens en fait un travail sérieux là
dessus public doit reconnaître cette
affaire pour d'une part ouvrir les
archives et puis faire un travail et
permettent à tout le monde de se
réapproprier cette histoire mais voyez
en quoi la mémoire à la des effets sur
l'histoire
[Musique]
lorsqu'une société ne sait plus où il en
est alors elle fait des lois pour dire
ce qui est bien et ce qui est mal mais
quand elle en est à faire des lois pour
dire ce qui est bien et ce qui est mal
ça veut dire qu'il n'ya plus un accord
dans la société si on écrit qu'il est
interdit de penser ceci ou cela ça veut
dire que on a déjà renoncé à défendre
une idée on a renoncé au débat on a plus
de dialogue commun il est vrai que la
manifestation de sétif est un événement
qui fait partie de l'histoire de france
et qui fait partie aussi l'histoire de
l'algérie
vous avez bien sûr en tête que il n'a
pas la même gravité que la guerre
mondiale qui se termine ce même 8 et 9
mai 1945 mais il a sa place dans un
autre chapitre de l'histoire de la
france dans un chapitre qui montrera
l'impasse de la colonisation comment on
ne peut pas vivre ensemble si l'on n'a
pas les mêmes droits et les mêmes
devoirs d'ailleurs il ya des lois
d'ailleurs quelquefois inacceptable
donc c'est plutôt la question de comment
faire en sorte qu'il y ait la place de
toute l'histoire de france c'est ça
l'enjeu véritable et moi je ne crois pas
qu'il y a si vous voulez une une
hiérarchie dans les morts par exemple
les morts de sétif guelma et rabat en
compte autant que les morts de la
deuxième guerre mondiale pourquoi elle
parce que ça a été d'une sauvagerie
total et moi je trouve que d'avoir une
liberté effectivement dans la recherche
dans l'enseignement en aucun cas on doit
obliger des chercheurs ou des salles et
moi même je fais des chaires des
recherches en sociologie
je n'accepterai pas qu'on m'impose un
sujet mais simplement qu'ils liberté
mais aussi qu'ils aient la possibilité
de l'ouverture des archives et que tout
le monde puisse travailler sur
l'ensemble des sujets qui le souhaitent
la loi ben elle peut elle peut s'avérer
des fois du point de vue de la
symbolique importante mais faut pas
qu'elle étouffe
les chercheurs bien évidemment c'est
bien naturel de confier des missions à
des historiens la mémoire on est dans
les derniers moments de la mémoire ce la
guerre d'algérie les participants auront
bientôt tous disparu donc c'est le
moment d'essayer de recueillir les
mémoires des uns et des autres donc
c'est une initiative qui est qui et qui
est bonne elle est d'autant meilleur que
les dirigeants algériens
soixante ans après l'indépendance
explique que tous les problèmes de leur
pays viennent de la colonisation
française
ce qui évidemment ne correspond en rien
à la réalité ils viennent de la façon
dont ils ont géré la rente pétrolière
qui est le répète et suant partage et
donc il est bon d'essayer de remettre
les choses à plat puisque les dirigeants
algériens en permanence ne propose à la
france que de payer par des larmes de
sang
les cent trente années de colonisation
ce qui ne favorise pas l'intégration des
nombreuses personnes qui arrivent
d'algérie et qui choisissent de vivre
dans ce pays criminels contre l'humanité
malgré tout il faut créer les conditions
de la réussite pour que pour favoriser
encore plus ce travail benjamin stora
fait aujourd'hui a ouvert une porte très
intéressante moi je ne suis pas ce
qu'ils jettent en bloc son travail
néanmoins il reste il reste des zones
d'ombré important la connaissance
historique et le croisement avec le
travail mémoriel que les uns et les
autres font ça ne s'oppose pas bien au
contraire ça s'enrichit et ça permet
surtout de prendre de la distance de ne
pas être enflammées et de deux justement
de pouvoir vivre comme on dit le fameux
vivre ensemble mais c'est d'abord
reconnaître comme mais ni le savoir
libère le savoir c'est formidable et
c'est pour ça qu'il faut permettre à la
jeunesse aux plus jeunes d'avoir la
possibilité mais à une condition de
développer l'esprit critique